[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
and we talk about whatever
we want hawk is here and steve just took
a bite
out of bart's desecration of fruitas
so i got this from the fruit man down
the street right and then i already has
uh tajin
and lime the best combination in the
world yo
but what happens if you need a little
bit of caffeine action
and then i put it on there and i'm like
i thought it was a joke
oh my god this looks good what if you
drink it like this oh no no no
you're not gonna drink it you have to
that's that spicy red bull
yeah too scary you don't want diarrhea
and you're
wearing like beige pants so no yeah dude
there's no way
you put we want red bull in yours no
what made you want to do that
i don't know you know they put alcohol
on fruits and stuff so i was like
hmm what what happened
and i put it on there did you guys ever
do those when you make the
with the gummies and the [ __ ] hell
yeah dude
are you kidding me oh jungle juice is so
good like i don't even drink
but whenever someone makes jungle juice
at a party i just gotta drink a little
bit
it's made with vodka right whenever they
get those like fish bowls with all the
different colors in it i'm in i'll drink
out of a fish bowl yep
i think that'd be fun every [ __ ]
thing you just put
somehow it always tastes good do you
think we'll ever go back to that point
where like
we don't even care whose hand's been in
it you know like
because there are those those like what
those jungle juice it's like everything
yeah your same cup that everyone's been
drinking they're like [ __ ] the ladle
i'm just gonna go straight in and then
now we're so like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i don't know if we're ever gonna go back
to that i don't think i ever left
i think it's gonna take like five years
for everyone to kind of like chill the
[ __ ] out yeah
recently i went to a thrift store and i
saw
they had this punch bowl and they had
like 12
like this is all glass too 12 cups
and then it's kind of like the old
school parties what you're talking about
it's like getting your cup and you just
dip it into the punch bowl and it was
there for 20
20 and i'm like oh my gosh i really want
to buy it but gross
gross because of that i don't want
people like doing the [ __ ]
dipping the cup and the the whole bowl
and contaminating the whole bowl
no thank you what if it's just you and
the family same household yeah um
i don't that's 12 cups 12 glasses
we're each gonna go through them all
yeah just a lot of dishes afterwards but
i think it'll be worth it for the
purchase for a 20
punch bowl kit come on dude 12. what i
did buy
for 20 is 12 salad
plates and they were glass and they were
pink and they're so [ __ ] cute and i'm
like i don't even need more plates but i
couldn't leave without buying it do you
guys think that
party fondue is [ __ ] over like it's a
business like it's over
what i don't think so i love those i
love them yeah
i think they'll be fine [ __ ] put the
drink in and you're like
because you do one piece at a time you
know what i mean chocolate
cherry sauce you can't beat it the whole
way
they're finding a band-aid in there a
band-aid
wait why would you find a bad dude a
[ __ ] snot-nosed kid
going in there digging in their hands
and then they lose no kids are invited
to my parties
yeah yeah and it's at the doctor's
office what so everyone's extra careful
i love cheese fondues she's fine he's
gonna be under the supervision of a
doctor yeah
but i had cheese i never had it no oh
wait i have i'm lying
no where do you get it in france hell of
a thing to say i know
right oh i remember in paris
it wasn't petty i actually was not a fan
no it was too
like cheesy greasy fatty i don't know
it was too heavy where did you get it i
think the first time was actually
it was but do you only do the things
that are like
from that like i don't know not here no
no no i like doing
it yeah i like doing it but i think no
because there's not
too many places in the states i feel
like you know there's those i forgot
what it's called but
there's like fondue restaurants i'm
pretty sure i went there by myself one
time too
it's not really a thing so you are a
loser sometimes yeah all the time
i have to get cheese fondue by yourself
i did i just wanted to order
it france to get cheese fondue no this
is in the states
and i felt kind of weird because um
the waitress really felt bad for me she
got a magazine or something
wait french people don't eat alone
french waitress felt bad for him that
was a huge hit the french waitress would
hate him
do you speak french no no
but yeah it was weird because she was
she kept waiting and was like
what if she was trying to hit on you
like you need some company well
ah the game was horrible then because i
didn't notice
so you don't know our culture you don't
know our royalty aka the kardashians
what do you know i don't know what do
you worship like obviously
i don't know
you obviously know all their names and
all the different provinces i don't see
that's the thing i don't even know
any of that either you know
stereotypically english food is not good
right
what's right is there anything that's
like
well actually this is actually really
good um it might be because i
grew up with it but there's this um
thing i love called
cornish pasty and it's like uh
it's like an empanada basically um
yeah yeah it's like a type of pastry um
but it has like an empanada meat
potatoes
onions sometimes carrots
is it kind of like a meat pie a little
bit it's like a shepherd
that looks good it looks like a pizza
pocket
very nice that's right they actually got
that from i mean it tastes exactly
how it looks and it's nice and warm and
yeah
um yeah things like that i i love it but
it's not really that
common or popular i feel like people
don't really know about it do you have a
good stereotypical american accent
hell yeah that's yours come on no no no
no no no
no no we've been roasting you all
[ __ ] day long say
our country's the best yeah our country
is the best
pretty good that's pretty good see i
like garth brooks
that's too much he's like garth brooks
i'm not crossing that line
i wouldn't say that either so you grew
up pretty global right like what
how old were you when you went to the uk
uh three okay and then from there
you grew up until how old like 2012.
japan or in japan out there and then 20.
to where
japan no to to england like
english land i am i'm sending them to
vegas same thing
england vegas and then he could come
back with a dope accent
vega vegas las vegas actually so he grew
up in
england until you were 12. and then you
went back to japan at 12
to what 20. oh dang so
do you do you like identify with either
one do you feel more comfortable with
one or the other not really
i mean i feel like parts of me yes but
um i don't know i don't know if it was
identity crisis or like
you know like when you're in england
people make
fun of you obviously because you're
different but then you think it's okay
because it's like oh well when i go back
to
japan
they're my people they still make fun of
you and they they found me more so it
was like count on a second
you know and it actually wasn't until i
moved to l.a and i saw you know uh
just different races culture beliefs
religion language i was like
oh [ __ ] it really doesn't matter you
know did you try to spread english
common law in japan
what would be the first thing you do i
don't know i feel like
um yeah just you know um certain things
are nice about england
certain things are nice about japan it
trips me out the hardest that you were
there
from three to twelve yeah and and then
japan
from 12 to 20 and then in la or the
states for the last 15 years
yeah you still retained your british
accent yeah i mean i feel like
i've definitely stopped using a lot of
slang and stuff because
every time the conversation doesn't move
forward
you know it becomes a question like what
does that mean yes he doesn't sound
full on like yeah so i think when i'm
londoner
why does he not no he doesn't
what's left when i first came here or if
i uh talk to my english friends i feel
like
i'm more english because you know
naturally you just adapt it's kind of
like if you're from
different parts of the states and you're
with your family you know you just
automatically
you know choose the quicker way to
communicate so i feel like
when you go back to texas my husband
because that's where he's going yeah
he uh his texas twang right right i
would pay
money to hear that i mean it's not heavy
but you could hear a little bit right
yeah it totally is subconscious too
right it's just like
match what's some english sling in it
[Laughter]
do you call people [ __ ] like pretty
regularly not really that's pretty
i mean i think the thing too is that a
lot of the words i didn't use
when i was 12 i don't really use much
do you say i wish i could say harry
potter or harry potter
yeah that's french
what up guys this episode of off the
record is brought to you by
fields so these days we've been having
like
pretty big goals for me and geo and
because of that we've been having to
work
late and i don't know how you are but
for me like if i work
too late my brain starts racing oh yeah
i'm the same you are yeah yeah yeah so
it keeps going racing racing i'm trying
to close my eyes and i got to go to
sleep because i got to wake up early
again
but it's really hard for me to sleep so
these days i've just taken a little bit
of feels
i put two drops underneath my tongue and
then it just kind of helps me relax
unwind and we're able to like enjoy like
tick tock or watching some tv together
without my brain still
stuck on the last thing i was working on
on my computer
so it really helped me kind of reduce
some of the sleep and i don't know if i
have anxiety but i definitely have like
these anxious feelings sometimes when i
know i have a big project coming up
yeah so taking that kind of helps calm
me down and i'm able to go to sleep and
actually wake up earlier on time and
more refreshed yeah i do the same thing
with
like um usually it's like to balance out
my caffeine because like throughout the
day
you know we're doing like 10 different
projects we're drinking coffee tea
whatever and then when i'm trying to go
to sleep
i'm still like going on this roller
coaster ride and i'm like what the hell
man
yeah so feels shout outs to you guys for
hooking us up it's super easy
easy to take just put a few drops under
your tongue
and then you feel the chill vibes and
wait for it to kick in
everyone you know will take different
doses so what's cool about it
is they have support and if you're new
to this stuff
they'll help you out with it you know
yeah also it's pretty awesome because
they just deliver this right to your
door so one of my favorite things about
fields too is
after you take it there's no addiction
no hangover so there's no after effects
that's the last thing that i want
so if you want to feel your best to
maybe give it a try feels.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com slash off
director to get 50
off your first order plus free shipping
thank you fields yeah so this is a weird
weird mix you know so do you visit or
before the pandemic
did you visit often uh well i have
family in japan so i try to go
at least once a year no and friends in
england so maybe not as often but
yeah i try to keep the connection are
you an illegal immigrant or
are you on a visa i'm a green card
holder oh
how did you get that i got the
01 special talent visa for three years
oh
[ __ ] you have to do a dance show for
them no you're at the end
of the [ __ ] immigration office
and then some old woman comes out and
it's like oh okay
i don't know if she's got the moves
you're going to america
it's pretty crazy because you pay a lot
of money and it's so much work to put
the paperwork together
really yeah do you get taxed like your
citizen here
so per state you would get taxes yeah
well green card's pretty solid except
you can't vote i think yeah
you're just you're almost like yeah i
think it's just voting and jury duty
yeah the stuff that most americans don't
do yeah but everything else i mean
with a japanese passport and green card
you know it's
pretty green card is a residence
permanent residence yeah
yeah so you don't so you can yeah travel
freely
you don't have to do jury duty that's
that's it that's so worth it
is it an actual card and is it actually
green
it's a natural green card yeah it is
yeah that's why they called it green
card yeah yeah cause sometimes they call
things and it's not yeah
yeah they didn't get too cute with it i
always hate that
like a pink slip for the car yeah
exactly it is pink though
with the blue rim yeah but it is pink
yeah it is a pink slip so what the heck
is the duchess anyway
honestly it's it's funny because i feel
like a lot of people assume that i would
know
so much about england because of the way
i shout but honestly
i feel like more people around me know
about well it makes sense because you
you left when you were 12. exactly so
you know good one so why do you need two
duchesses you got justice of york and
the duchess of cambridge
or just pick one i asked them wait what
what how many dutches do they have
i think they have like 70. wait do you
know how that stuff works so there's
like prince of wales right is that
prince of england i asked this question
and we looked it up
and the prince of wales is just a title
he's not an actual prince of wales i
feel like there's a lot of those left
huh
like maybe was back then but now it's
like that carries on but it's not but
the prince of wales is basically
the king or like charles right yeah
who's the one that was hanging out with
uh sandusky not sandusky
uh epstein who's who's that oh andrew
albert andrew albert's the husband of
the queen correct
he's sick right now albert his name is
phillip correct never mind
[Laughter]
prince albert is when you get a dick
that's why i was thinking about
am i not saying this right now which
challenge
they're like that's a piercing i'm like
his name is phillip
which is crazy yo he looks like dead
already
like he's been looking dead for quite
some time prince albert no
hello i can't keep track of them i don't
know who's who
damn [ __ ] queen elizabeth is gonna
probably most likely outlive
this fool she lives forever
she goes no he's 99 she eats [ __ ]
ginger babies for power or something
for sure that's the recipe actually for
power and to stay alive a lot of adrenal
chrome i'm sure
she's 94. did you get your visa after
being a part of quest and all that uh
first phase was
before quest as a student or yeah so
you get this thing called opt if you
graduate with an associate's degree
and you can basically uh work within the
field that you studied in
and i was uh studying art so it was
pretty broad you know so
so during that i did so you think you
can dance and um
built a lot of like resume in that field
okay and then i was able to apply for
the o1
and then 01 was three years so the goal
was to
do enough stuff so that you can apply
for a green card oh
have you ever been in a dance off before
i don't know if i've ever called it a
dance-off but
like when you guys are in an argument
and the only way to settle your argument
that's the definition have you ever had
to save a rec center before
yeah that too what kind of situation is
that
all right they have government funding
i feel like every dance trope movie is
like
oh no they're these greedy bastards are
gonna take down the rec center
where are we gonna dance man we have
nowhere to dance has dancing ever been
illegal in your town
no that's footloose right yo we did we
did a [ __ ] jk news
where um there was an old law in japan
of no dancing after a certain time oh
yeah yeah
and it was like they had yeah and then
so the clubs were getting shut down
because of no
dance yeah yeah that's great i saw that
thing too yeah
it's like a dance police it's weird what
is it like they just control their
expressions or like what
i forgot the reason but it's an old law
on like
no dancing after a certain time or or
did you guys hear about that
really weird unexplained phenomenon
where it was a long time ago and there
was this group of people
for a certain amount of days it was like
days long oh they just would not
stop dancing a lot of people died it was
contagious
yeah yeah yeah it was in europe it was
like a they say
like they're calling it possession
witchcraft whatever
but they think that it was in the bread
like the bread molded and it was like
the same as like eating magic mushrooms
so people were just high as [ __ ]
i was 15 18. yeah and then they were
dancing it was called the beauty
dancing i wonder if they danced good it
looked like they were dancing but they
weren't actually dancing or something
wasn't it
is that what they were somewhere between
50 and 400 people
took the dancing for days they started
dancing and a lot of people started
dancing out in the streets
and they couldn't stop dancing and then
people were dying from dancing too much
damn they died from dancing yeah imagine
and that's how edm's were
invented i guess that's why
the masses are so crazy in europe dude
1818 was the first nbc
let's monetize off of that have your
friends ever come to you in need and
you're like i don't dance anymore
we need you back from retirement dude
look
is always the same you know there's some
love interest
and always what's your favorite step up
movie you're like the coach
you were like a dance star in the 80s
right and they're like we need you back
we need you you're the only one that
could train us just a janitor
it's like those days are over man that
was just a silly dream i had [ __ ] that
he yells i don't get it tells him to get
out and it's like a trauma incident
because like they had like a like they
broke their ankle during a performance
and then they lost and then they're like
i'm never going back to that ever again
man that was a stupid dream
why is it all the same i hate it well
you do something really original then
with your body right now right now
now i have a question what is your most
favorite performance
story or like something that happened
during a performance
oh um or like a project
something yeah yeah yeah well um
that's a good one well when we did abdc
the second time for one of our
performances
nice flex it's the one that they won
yeah the second time it's um it's a
competition so it's super stressful
right and i think it's the second time
everyone's
every team is a winner so it's not like
a certain week you can
have it easy like every week everyone
someone's eliminated
yeah but everyone like they have the
pride being the winners of their season
whatever so
oh they come in so hard every week so
um yeah there's literally just no sleep
and there's camera blocking so
i think you're already stressed but
after the one of the performance we did
uh you guys all stay in the same hotel
or something
or you get to go home do they keep the
two dance crews apart so that you guys
don't
have dance offs uh i can't remember no i
think the second time
we were able to go home but all you had
the option of staying in the hotel
but i think half of us stayed i can't
remember um
but other than when you're sleeping
you're always together anyways you know
so it doesn't really matter
but yeah one after one of the last
performances we did with a
with a yellow bench um right after we
got off the
stage we just saw in the circle we just
all started
crying wow wow cause you finished i
don't know no that wasn't even the last
performance but
there was something in the in the
performance or just the situation
that it and it was really like a
contagious thing i don't know if one
person started it just like
transmitted and it was such a weird
feeling you know
and even when we would right before we
got off stage when we were on there it
was like
i don't know how to describe it but it's
almost like
time and space didn't matter
kind of thing it was really [ __ ]
weird but it was just like
to be able to do that and share that and
produce that kind of thing
that's all that mattered in that minute
two minutes or whatever
you know and um yeah it's really hard to
describe but i think that was yeah
has anyone ever figured out why you guys
were crying or no
i don't know maybe we were just [ __ ]
maybe it was like in those couple of
minutes you like
everyone watching was like oh i want
world peace
like some [ __ ] like that maybe they
would spread yeah
i don't know i mean it makes sense that
you're like how much you guys
worked up to that point and then you
finished it and also you're so proud of
your performance yeah yeah yeah and like
what you gave it
i get it have you ever had a crew member
almost not make it to a dance
competition and then you guys are gonna
have to be disqualified
no but we actually did have one where um
steve was in a car accident
i think on the way to the competition
i think he ended up still coming because
he got an uber or something
because otherwise you would get
disqualified they're like we're missing
one member man
they're like hey it says on the rules
you gotta have eight who's the rules
and then the grandpa comes out like oh
do it
we'll never save the rec center i don't
know hunter or honey
i don't know we'll never see it
therefore it goes full circle it's
always about the recordings
at the last minute i'm here guys i'm
here but it really was like that moment
because he got in the
[ __ ] car accident you know you're
gonna have to rework the whole routine i
think we were supposed to be then he
showed up and then
yeah we won and we were like yeah then
you guys do a routine that you guys
haven't practiced yet but they're like
it's ready it's ready for this moment
and then you guys do that yeah that
trick
let's do it right dude fidget did you
yo can we make a dance movie you should
all just dance
bring all the stereotypical moments in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you